bonsoir le 7 8 en direct à partir de 18h
du lundi au jeudi une heure pour faire
le point sur l'actualité locale avec nos
reportages et puis nos invités et
également dans un instant le sommaire
complet déjà bon soir valérie valerio
ribot et chaque semaine on vous retrouve
pour la chronique de l'environnement ont
fait le point sur l'actualité dans le
département oui absolument ce soir nous
allons faire la connaissance de la
nouvelle directrice de la maison de
l'environnement des sciences et du
développement durable qui nous
expliquera les projets à venir de cette
maison qui s'occupent d'environnement
mais pas seulement et nous verrons ça
avec notre invité
la nouvelle directrice qui sera donc sur
ce plateau la chronique de
l'environnement dans une quinzaine une
vingtaine de minutes aux alentours 18h20
donc si vous nous suivez en direct la
suite du sommaire de ce 27 novembre 7 en
images à présent la deuxième journée
d'ouverture pour les restos du coeur
dans les yvelines à l'antenne de plaisir
à vue en six ans le nombre
d'inscriptions progressé de 65%
les femmes seules avec enfants sont les
principales concernées nous en parlerons
avec et daniel favier vice président des
restos du coeur des yvelines il est sur
ce plateau
une initiative solidaire menée en ce
moment par la mission locale de plaisir
l'organisme propose à des jeunes
bénéficiaires de faire du vélo en tandem
avec une personne malvoyante objectif
gagner de la confiance en soi et chasser
les a priori témoignages et explications
à travers reportages et interviews
une découverte tout en saveur à la
maison de quartier théodore monod a cuit
en cours la cuisine malgache est des
plats typiques ont été réalisés par les
adhérents vous les voyez et puis les
monstres cela n'intéresse pas que les
enfants une peuple également la
littérature pour adultes une exposition
consacrée à ce thème se déroule jusqu'à
la fin de la semaine à la médiathèque le
phare c'est important et puis je
recevrai également ce soir béatrice
goodman elle est adjointe à la
démocratie locale à la verrière et elle
se charge de mettre en place le conseil
municipal des jeunes qui sera élu au
mois de janvier
un apprentissage de la démocratie nous
en parlerons d'ici la fin de cette
émission
l'ump se déchire depuis maintenant dix
jours les élus du département des
yvelines sont en première ligne valérie
pécresse député de la 2e circonscription
responsables du parti sur le plan local
et bien sûr soutien de françois fillon
candidate au poste de secrétaire
national au niveau secrétaire général
national n'a pas manqué de s'exprimer
tout oloron 2
derniers jours sur le chaos actuel est
depuis ce matin c'est david douillet
député également lui de la 12e
circonscription qui se fait entendre
il a publié sur son blog et via les
réseaux sociaux le communiqué suivant il
n'y a plus de solution possible à la
crise que nous traversons la suite à la
décision de françois fillon de créer un
groupe distinct au sein de l'ump
rassemblement ump c'est son nom il en
appelle un arbitrage de nicolas sarkozy
afin de sauver notre famille politique
ce sont ses termes interrogé sur bfm tv
celui qui a été ministre des sports du
gouvernement fillon a indiqué que
l'ancien président de la république
était lui aussi excédé par ce qui se
passait et devrait prochainement prendre
la parole
rappelons tout de même aussi que dans
les yvelines françois fillon est arrivé
en tête lors de l'élection interne avec
60% des suffrages
il a reçu le soutien des principales
figures locales telles que gérard
larcher le sénateur maire de rambouillet
jean françois copé était lui plus isolés
ils étaient soutenus notamment par jean
frédéric poisson le député également du
parti chrétien démocrate dans la 12/10
pardon circonscription